Alabama's Attorney General is suing the
mayor of Birmingham for covering up a
confederate memorial that 52 foot
monument honoring southern soldiers and
sailors is now surrounded by wooden
panels it is one of many Confederate
symbols across the country that could be
removed in the wake of the weekend
violence in Charlottesville some cities
are already taking away statues and
plaques Omar Villafranca is in
Birmingham at the monument the mayor is
targeting Omar good morning good morning
this monument was put up in 1905 by the
United Daughters of the Confederacy
there's also a new state law that says
monuments that have been around for 40
years cannot be removed or altered and
this wall is considered an alteration
Mayor William Bell says he plans to
fight the law because he wants this
monument pulled down we have no real
connection with the Civil War but we are
definitely a civil rights city in terms
that this was the cradle of the Civil
Rights Movement Mayor William Bell says
Birmingham was founded after the end of
the Civil War and the monument conflicts
with the city's deep history in the
struggle for civil rights you don't want
to see it no because again think about
what he represents the Confederacy was
an act of sedition it was an act of
treason Tuesday night he ordered city
workers to put up plywood walls around
the memorial that has stood here for
more than a century Birmingham is not
alone Baltimore's mayor had four
Confederate monuments removed without
warning before dawn Wednesday I did what
was right for my city that was my intent
and it is done other Confederate
monuments are under consideration for
removal
some have been vandalized or even
destroyed at least four people have been
arrested in connection to the toppling
of that Confederate statue in Durham
North Carolina Monday night
mayor Bell says the monument in
Birmingham represents something that
should have been put to rest a long time
ago you're a black mayor of a city that
was crucial in the civil rights movement
what do you want to happen to that
statue I would like to see us giving it
back to the Daughters of the Confederacy
and if they want to put it on private
property you know that's their business
we reached out to the United Daughters
of the Confederacy but did not hear back
mayor Bell says this statue does not
belong in the city that he says broke
the back of segregation in America
Charlie thanks Omar